il m'a sakho bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
et une élection qui suscite l'inquiétude
de la communauté internationale quels
sont les enjeux de ce scrutin
dumont bercy de votre invitation
les enjeux de ce scrutin sont sont
énormes pour le peuple de kylie avant
tout j'aimerais bien vous dire que cette
élection présidentielle est
anticonstitutionnelle ll n'est pas la
volonté du peuple du xi donc à partir de
là je pense que on peut s'attendre à
tout dans cette élection présidentielle
sauf aux élections transparentes
équitables
c'est qui va aboutir en certainement a
dit à des violences post électorales que
personne ne le souhaite dans l'autre
pays et des violences imposées
encore une fois par la volonté funeste
de alpha condé de l'est pas céder le
pouvoir de façon démocratique
alors on l'a dit la campagne
présidentielle a elle même été assez
agiter dans un climat de tension alpha
condé qui a 82 ans brigue un troisième
mandat on sait qu'il a changé la
constitution pour pouvoir justement se
présenter à nouveau mais dans quelle
posture se présente il cette fois ci
qu'est ce qui est différent par rapport
au précédent scrutin par rapport au
précédent scrutin
il y avait une légalité c'était dans un
esprit du combat démocratique même si
alpha condé at il mal à lui et lui
c'était acceptable mais là nous pouvons
pas l'accepter la majorité des guides
ailleurs ne veulent pas de cette
élection
les guinéens exige une d'une alternance
politique pour plusieurs raisons parce
que d'abord leurs conditions de vie sont
misérables et ça depuis des dizaines
d'années donc au delà de ça vouloir se
maintenir au pouvoir
parce que alpha condé et son clan ont la
main mise sur les institutions du pays à
savoir la cour constitutionnelle la cour
suprême
la commission électorale nationale
indépendante et le fichier électoral
taillé à sa mesure des forces de
sécurité et de défense du pays de
l'administration pour imposer à ce point
pour à ce pauvre peuple de guinée cette
élection pour nous c'est vraiment
inacceptable voilà donc on situ les
élections que nous ne voulons pas et
nous allons tout faire même au delà de
maintenant faire en sorte que l'état de
droit soit rétabli en guinée de façon
pacifique
donc encore une fois cette élection ne
présage rien de bon en face à alpha
condé
onze candidats le principal opposant
d'ailleurs au chef de l'état
cellou dallen diallo on a l'impression
qu'un qu'un duel semble inévitable est
ce que l'ancien premier ministre de
guinée est en position favorable selon
vous ces serments c'est ce que je viens
de le dire par rapport au douze
candidats vous remarquerez que sur les
douches il ya presque vingt neuf
candidats cette élite c'est à dire qui
était prévu pour légitimer cette
élection anticonstitutionnel de notre
pays
donc par rapport à ces du dallage et
pense que le l'enjeu de ce scrutin
électoral et je suis davance elf
accordée à tous les leviers pour
l'emporter ce qui fait craindre au
peuple de guinée des violences post
électorales assez terrible pour nous
vous savez comme je disais il ya
quelques secondes
alpha condé et son clan ont la main mise
sur les institutions
ils ont la mainmise sur les ressources
du pays
ils ont la mainmise sur son
administration sur les forces de défense
et de sécurité
donc à partir de là il peut vous imposer
leur volonté et cette volonté là ces
deux guerriers vie dans cette élection
dès le premier tour c'est qui à mon avis
scra contestable puisque ça ne sera pas
la volonté du peuple de guinée donc tout
à craindre que nous assumions au vert
dès maintenant
assez difficile pour la guinée sous le
plan de stabilité et paix et autres
quatre membres de la commission
nationale électorale indépendante ont
dénoncé hier des manquements et des
violations du code électoral est ce que
vous attendez justement à des fraudes
massives lors de ces élections
alors vous savez comme on dit les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets alpha
condé si dans ses habitudes de frauder
et ça depuis une dizaine d'années mais
on pouvait encore accepté même si
c'était pas démocratique
mais là je pense que il le refera le
frère fera sans aucun doute encore une
fois c'est pourquoi moi personnellement
j'ai demandé à mes militants au peuple
de guinée de n'est pas là cette élection
parce que voilà ça donnera des
lendemains
ah si terrible pour nous je comprends la
crainte de des membres de la commission
électorale nationale indépendante
c'est pas une surprise pour moi et c'est
pas une surprise pour les guinéens ben
haim sakho merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président du parti
changement progrès unités pour la guinée
c'est vrai que je vous remercie madame